okay it's 10 a.m uh so we're gonna start
up uh today's meeting of the house
election law committee and I'm not going
to forget the pledge this time so we'll
start off with the pledge
all right okay
um today we're going to start off with a
HB 324
um so I am officially opening the house
hearing on the executive executive law
Committee hearing on HB 324 I believe
representative Lane will be introducing
for representative Muirhead who is not
with us today that's correct and I think
we're doing a public hearing not an
executive I'm sorry I meant to say
public hearing I got the pledge right
you know what you want from me
it takes a village
okay
um uh thank you I am Connie Lane I am
representative for Concord War II
um which is known as Merrimack District
16. so I'm here in place of uh
representative Muirhead because he's out
of town to introduce his bill HB 324
which proposes public financing for
campaigns
since citizens united the Spring Court
case one of the most prominent concerns
about our flawed election cycle is dark
money
uh wealth
wealth is a significant barrier to
participation for candidates and for
donors
our current system is dominated by big
money
uh and
results in an unrepresentative
government that the Privileges the
interests of the few the wealthy few
including corporations
public company financing offers
candidates the choice to drop out of the
big money Chase and to focus on talking
to constituents and getting small
donations
the infiltration of dark money creates
conflicts of interest for elected
officials are you representing your
constituents or are you representing the
people who gave you the money
over the last 10 years more than 12
jurisdictions have either adopted new
public financing systems or strengthened
their existing ones
New York became the first state to enact
a Statewide financing program
since
citizens united
and with that I am going to stop talking
and let the speakers who are following
me to answer your questions thank you
thank you and um we're not going to be
asking representative Lane questions
because she's doing a courtesy for
representative mirrorhead so we'll um
we'll let her off um just so the
committee and everybody present knows
um this bill was not it was
inadvertently scheduled it should have
been scheduled for next week but had
already been noticed so we are going to
do representative Muirhead a courtesy
and I believe we will reopen
um the hearing we will hear everyone
that's here today to speak to the bill
um and they are a fair game for
questions but just in the interest of
transparency it was a an error had
already gone out we couldn't take it
back but we also didn't want to
disrespect representative Muirhead by he
asked us we just it just ships passing
of the night so with that
um we've got two representatives from
open democracy Miss Inc do you want to
go first do you have a preference okay
foreign
good morning chair and members of the
committee for the record my name is
Olivia Zink I live in Franklin New
Hampshire but open democracy of the
executive director of open democracy
action
um which I'm the executive director and
today
and the governor governor sununu issued
a proclamation
um so this is the best birthday gift you
could give Granny D
um is having a public hearing on this
important effort we need to reduce the
influence of money and politics
and we can do that and increase the
voice of average citizen by passing this
voluntary voter owned elections
um this bill will
work to create small donors uh so you
would have to qualify for to opt into
this bill qualify by collecting small
donor donations and then be eligible for
the voter owned voter dollars Warren
Rudman said I challenge my party to
return return to the roots of Teddy
Roosevelt and take up a challenge from a
century ago for real lasting solutions
to our current campaign Finance which is
known as citizen-funded elections Public
Funding elections or voter owned
elections is sort of all known
um this is a common in across the
country 24 states have some kind of
solutions five states Maine Connecticut
Hawaii Minnesota and Arizona
um have full Public Funding and then
some states have just partial Public
Funding of offices 13 states
um Inc have some option Maryland has
County jurisdictions eligible and then
there are other jurisdictions where
cities like Seattle or Oakland have
Public Funding and we candidates for the
president can take up Public Funding of
Elections this reduces or stabilizes the
cost for running for office we've all
seen the cost for running for office
increase year after year after year
um this would reduce the amount of time
that candidates spend fundraising and
would allow candidates to talk to
Everyday voters
this increases
equality in our political system it
encourages more competition
it decreases special interests and
out-of-state interests
this bill does have
does not contain the same funding
mechanism as the Arizona
did that was stricken down by the
Supreme Court
Maine also has a similar or not a little
bit different but a Public Funding
system that they've had for many years
and it allows Maine to pass bold
bipartisan legislation that's demanded
by the public if the industry objects
and so I think it's really important for
us to underline that we want voters to
be accountable uh politicians to be
accountable to voters and not to the big
big money in the in the system
um there is a another quote in my
testimony from the former Arizona
governor which basically I'm just going
to summarize says that they are not
they're able to pass
policies that they weren't able to pass
prior to Public Funding because of big
Pharma not allowing them you know sort
of getting in the way of passing
important prescription drugs legislation
that they were able to successfully pass
after they passed these systems
um the time is now to Institute a policy
that for more fair transparent
and just systems
um I want to just sort of say that this
is not the first time this bill has been
heard by the committee
um you had a um
bipartisan study committee committee
chaired by Brad cook a numerous amount
of years ago and then in 2008 you had a
feasibility commission so this this has
been studied twice and has been
introduced a number of times prior and I
would recommend ought to pass on House
Bill
um 324. I also with me today Senator
former Senator Jim rubins is unable to
be here but I have testimony for him and
I also have a petition signed by a
number of people and their testimony as
well and testimony of Joe Bagshaw from
Center Conway who was unable to make it
down so happy to take any questions you
might have about
any questions from the committee from
um I had a couple I was reading over
this bill we received a lot of emails
about this I'm sure the committee got
them as well
um one of the things that was in the
emails was says that this was publicly
funded
um and I think on page 11
um it creates a for the interests of uh
transparency the fiscal note for this
bill is not available yet
um it's on the back of the bill OLS
wasn't able to generate it in time but
my understanding of it is it creates a
like a Citizens fund similar to like
Connecticut
um and one of the things that in my
doing my research on the bill
um and I think those kind of misleading
the emails we got was the the bill
um
the bill takes in donations from the
public correct
um so are you aware of the other states
when they've had these sort of funds
um how many people have donated to the
fund voluntarily we're not talking about
the voter dollars you get we're talking
about actual money here
so I will say that other states have
funded the main funds them from their
general fund Connecticut has a separate
fund that this comes from to fund
elections Seattle pays for them by
property taxes so this is a uniquely New
Hampshire way of allowing you know
spending a dollar from our general fund
and allowing for as you'll see there on
page 11.
um the voluntary contributions so it can
be populated by voluntary contributions
as well as a fee for uh election law
campaign Finance violations so any
campaign Finance violations will then be
allocated to this fund
um and then there's interest on the fund
and a couple of other things listed
um
as well as the governor could issue a
warrant which is under the appropriation
section of the bill to fund the bill so
there
um that is an important thing that we
need to discover and and work for a New
Hampshire solution to the pop to get big
that's all I had is my um yes um
representative kindy sorry I just so I
understand
um this bill doesn't do anything to
restrict big money does it
this bill is voluntary
um so just to be clear this bill would
create a system that candidates will
have to opt in candidates can still use
our current system and in other states
where they have these systems you see
participation rate about 70 75 percent
so in in no other state does this
universally solve a problem the court
has been very clear that you can't
mandate a system like this it has to be
a voluntary system and so it's complying
with all Court objections to to getting
money out of politics but I will say
that in other states that have had these
voluntary opt-in systems you have seen
High participation because
candidates want to be accountable to the
to the voters and voters demand
participation in in systems like this so
um thank you for the question and yes it
is a hundred percent voluntary
and it would be just for executive
Council and governors races to start
um and it if those work then the
commission could expand it to other
races
further questions from the committee
all right seeing none uh thank you Miss
sink next up also from open democracy it
was going to be uh Sarah
good morning my name is Sarah Lobdell
I'm the program coordinator of open
democracy and a voter in Keene New
Hampshire
my testimony hones in on this bill
specifically rather than a broad
overview of publicly funded elections
um
and so the system outlined in HB 324 is
good for both voters and candidates of
all parties
um and I recommend the committee adopt
an ought to pass vote
as voters and taxpayers we pay more
every day for our current system of
privately funded elections in New
Hampshire than we would for voter owned
elections we pay higher prices for goods
and services such as utilities and
Health Care regularly for example
because wealthy donors are able to buy
influence through campaign donations and
then expecting Returns on investment
through policies favorable to these
donors at the taxpayers expense
a place this is particularly troubling
is with the executive Council so
executive counselors approve contracts
for a third of New Hampshire's seven
billion dollar budget while at the same
time receiving uh potentially receiving
campaign donations from the groups whose
contracts they may soon vote on in these
instances
um will the most qualified contractor
get the bid with the state or the
contractor who contributed the most to
the executive counselors campaign
executive counselors and awarding
contracts intentionally or
subconsciously to their biggest owners
risk approving potentially unqualified
contractors and any errors resulting
from this come at the taxpayers expense
with the voter owned elections outlined
in HB 324 there is a limit to how much
money is dispersity selection voters
know how much money is in the fund where
that money is coming from and candidates
as well know where their campaign
contributions are coming from uh prior
to the election and cannot be swayed by
donations for example from lobbyists
once elected
elected officials are free to perform
the responsibilities of their office
without bias and with only the best
interest of the Granite State voters in
mind
I wanted to raise also that at about 9
A.M this morning there were 246 sign-ins
and support online for this bill and
only four opposed and with my testimony
I have an outline specifically honing in
on the voter dollars part of this bill
um of a study from Seattle's democracy
vouchers program and the successes that
questions from the committee
singman thank you a reminder to those in
attendance if you do have things you
want to submit to the committee please
um hold on to them and give it straight
to the clerk um it stops the distraction
of paper shuffling While others are
given their testimony so in the interest
of being fair to everyone
um not that I don't enjoy things coming
across my desk but it's hard not to look
down
um next up is going to we just uh we'll
do uh Corinne Dodge from dairy
Miss Dodge welcome to the election law
committee
where's you can take you can bring them
here to the clerks it's okay
've got to press the silver button right
in front of you it'll turn red
oh I knew that thank you
good morning chairman and house election
law members
thank you for honoring my right to speak
today my name is Corrine Dodge I live in
as a New Hampshire voter I hate the fact
that my voice is being drowned out by
excessive secret secret
and especially out of state donations
pouring into New Hampshire at election
Time by Lodge and multinational
corporations and by a tiny percentage
and a very wealthy individuals
currently candidates wanting to run or
rerun for our New Hampshire office of
Governor our executive Council must be
either independently wealthy
are willing and able to raise exorbitant
exorbitant amounts of money from large
corporations and from very wealthy
donors individuals
in effect the extreme amounts of these
donations make candidates obliged to do
the bidding of the donors whose agenda
is most often
in opposition to Everyday citizens
can't even begin to compete with wealthy
donors citizens like myself
consequently I also hate the fact that
when I speak to public officials I know
that my needs as a constituent are going
to be secondary to the needs of
extremely wealthy donors and
corporations
a number of years ago I sat in a chair
just like this at a hearing just like
this for a bill very similar to this one
I was asked by one of your colleagues if
I would be willing to share my tax
dollars to be used to pay for voter
owned elections
if asked that same question today my
answer would be more than a simple yes
I've learned a lot since then
if asked today my answer would be yes I
absolutely am willing to pay my share of
tax tax dollars to support a voter voter
owned elections because that would be
foreign than watching my household
budget for home heating fuel electricity
prescription drugs dwindle
even as I see the corporate pro profits
arising outrageously
I want a government that is actually
responsible to the needs of all New
Hampshire constituents
I ask that you protect the right of all
New Hampshire citizens to have their
Collective voices heard and considered
amend
hb324 if you must
but I ask that you amend with integrity
and with consideration
for constitution for the constituents of
New Hampshire past three to four please
thank you
are there any will you be taking
questions Mr
will I be I'm sure absolutely are there
any questions from the committee uh
representative bone
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
the question but as I see this I don't
will this have any effect at all on on
people running for office that have a
lot of money from previous campaign
donations or other outside agencies from
running ads on TV and whatnot
how will this affect that I do believe
when I've read the bill and it was hard
to go through all that but I do believe
there's some kind of a con in somebody
else may know I am not an expert on the
bill but I believe there is a
contingency for someone who has run in
another election
there's some requirements on what the
extra money they have and maybe somebody
can can confirm that but that was my
understanding
this bill isn't going to it's not going
to change
everything overnight but if we do
nothing it'll get worse that I know
I believe um if there's a clause in
there it says you cannot use previous
campaign funds just if I'm wrong on that
please correct me but I did read the
Bill
thank you any other questions for missed
watch
all right thank you Miss Dodge thank you
oh yeah I gotta go next up I guess
um that's not the right stack
um let's go with uh Bob Perry from
Stratford New Hampshire Mr Perry welcome
back
foreign
thank you very much for the greeting
my focus this bill focuses on two races
uh race for governor and the race for
executive Council my focus is on the
one of the most powerful entities in
state government is one that is arguably
least known by the General Public
it is one charge with the authority and
responsibility of
approving or not all contracts having a
value of ten thousand dollars or more of
course that would include
construction contracts
approving or not the spending of a major
portion of the approximately 5.2
billion dollars appropriated annually by
our legislature
approving or not the appointments of
District Superior and Supreme Court
Justices as well as appointments of
members to a myriad of boards committees
and commissions
being responsible to serve as quote
advocates for the people end quote
being responsible to ensure that those
appointed to the executive branch are
quote all responsible to the citizens of
New Hampshire and not to special
interests end quote
there is specific recognition therefore
that the council is vulnerable to the
pressures of special interests and that
it is the duty of each member to serve
as advocates for the people
while it is plus not possible to know
the inner workings of the human mind
and in this case how many how many
affects decision making among everyone
in the position of power
it is not impossible
every day our jury system sorts the
wheat from the chaff by convicting
defendants based on circumstantial
evidence and by invoking their own
common sense
I cite an example of the application of
Common Sense
in 2020 YouTube a campaign for governor
Ed
by Andrew valensky he prefaced his
remarks by saying quote people have a
right to be cynical about money in
politics end quote
he continued indicating he received an
unsolicited check in the amount of five
hundred dollars from a Fortune 100
accounting company an Enterprise with
which he had no knowledge or
relationship
the timing of this check caused the
candidate to conclude it was sent to
influence his decision
as then member of the executive Council
on a two million dollar no bid contract
involving the same company
he destroyed the check during the video
we can use our common sense to conclude
there will be those who will through
their contribution at least attempt to
in the 2020 executive Council campaign
1.33 million dollars came from in-state
contributions almost 218 thousand
dollars came from out of state and in
excess of sixty six hundred dollars
could not be traced
there should be no campaign contribution
that is untraceable
we know however that doc Marty permeates
politics
which is impact the impetus for HB 324
which requires complete disclosure
unlike the current system
and candidates must disavow
contributions from
outside organizations
for 30 years I was employed by the
state's superior court system and worked
with honorable people
one of whom offered to me the following
viewpoints
quote
Bob you're not a young man anymore
end quote
that was 25 years ago
yeah I silently disagreed
but he also advised that perception is
reality
that was not disputed
I cannot I cannot tell you unequivocally
that money is influencing decision
making on the executive Council nor can
anyone here tell me that it does
I can tell you the common sense dictates
that it can which brings us back to the
concept of perception being reality
HB 324 will not quiet the Skeptics but
it will be a step in the right direction
and its structure proven to provide
tangible benefits
I urge ought to pass on 324.
thank you thank you Mr Perry will you be
taking questions from the committee sure
are there questions from the committee
we'll see that's easy thank you so much
thank you
um last up to speak uh that I have for a
pink card uh is Linda Bundy from antrum
New Hampshire
good morning chairman and members of
house election law
my name is Linda Bundy and I'm from
antrum I support HB 324.
the current system of funding political
campaigns by private donations has led
to increasingly expensive campaigns with
wealthy donors and corporations exerting
undue influence in elections at all
levels
politicians in New Hampshire have
received large donations from
individuals as well as hospitals
Insurance Groups pharmaceutical
corporations the energy industry and
Communications companies
such a system directly affects who runs
for office and which pieces of
legislation are put into law candidates
of moderate means have difficulty
competing against those funded by Deep
Pockets
the opinions and issues of the wealthy
Drive the political agenda everyday
voters hold less weight with the
candidates who must spend an inordinate
amount of time soliciting donations even
after being elected
New Hampshire voters want change in
campaign funding according to a survey
conducted in New Hampshire by public
policy polling in 2018
a bipartisan majority of Voters believe
that big money is a problem in our
elections and would support a system
like the one proposed in HB 324 I've
included a link to the survey at the end
of my testimony
the solution for this situation is to
reform the funding of campaigns so that
candidates and elected officials are
motivated to serve the citizens of New
Hampshire rather than big big businesses
if enacted HB 324 would be a first step
in such reform candidates have to meet
certain criteria to be eligible for
voter dollars and registered voters
receive four 25 certificates that they
may assign to the participating
candidates of their choice participation
by candidates and voters is voluntary
as a result of this reform engagement
between candidates and voters would
increase the number of financially
viable candidates would grow and they
would have to work to make voters
believe they are the best choice to
receive voter dollars
candidates Focus would turn toward their
local constituents and the issues that
concern them
candidates who wish to participate in
public funding for their campaigns must
collect a minimum number of small
donations 2 500 for the office of
governor and 500 for the office of
executive counselor the amount of each
donation is between five and two hundred
fifty dollars for governor and between
five and one hundred twenty five dollars
for executive counselor
HB 324 is limited to the campaigns for
governor and executive Council
because the governor and the council are
responsible for decisions involving
large tax dollar expenditures their
offices are subject to lobbying and
financial support from donors with high
interest in how that money is spent
this situation makes these offices ideal
for Public Funding as a way to reduce
the effects of these donor influences
focusing on just six elections makes
implementation of the system a
what are the advantages of this system
of voter-owned elections candidates of
modest means are able to run for office
they must reach out to voters and
explain why they deserve voter
certificates even voters who normally
could not afford to donate to campaigns
can contribute and feel that they have a
voice in the election
greater participation by a broader range
of candidates and voters leads to
elected officials who more accurately
represent the citizens of New Hampshire
of course
funding of this system is an important
consideration the report of the
bipartisan 2008 commission to study the
feasibility of Public Funding of state
election campaigns has a two-page list
of 64 ideas for sources for Public
Funding which I have attached to my
testimony along with a link to the full
report
Arizona the city of Seattle and our
fellow New England states of Maine and
Connecticut have well established Public
Funding systems for State elections that
have been in place for years
HB 324 provides a workable proven way to
improve campaign funding in New
Hampshire in the interest of increasing
Grassroots participation by candidates
and voters in our elections and greater
engagement between candidates and voters
I ask that you vote ought to pass on
this bill
thank you are there any questions from
the committee
seeing none thank you um last person I
had signed up which just came in um Jane
welcome to election law
I am Jay Armstrong from sitter
and I have copies of my testimony here I
also have cop copies of
testimony from Liz tantarelli who is
president of the League of Women Voters
of New Hampshire and I happen to know
she lives in Newberry and has a very
very long driveway and their snow blower
broke so
bills to create a system of Public
Funding have a long history in New
Hampshire
in 1997 a small group consisting of past
legislators and interested citizens was
formed to study the issue of Public
Funding of election campaigns
I participated in that committee as a
member of the League of Women Voters of
New Hampshire
Doris haddock granny D joined us after
she finished walking across America to
promote campaign Finance reform
we created the organization Grant
Granite State clean elections and with
name changes that organization still
exists as open democracy and works
tirelessly for Public Funding of
Elections
in 2000 Senate Bill 447 creating a
Public Funding system for New
Hampshire's top three offices past the
Senate and failed narrowly in the house
in addition to legislative bills there
have been study committees a bipartisan
commission and a blue ribbon task force
but still no Statewide system of Public
Funding
over the same period of time the amount
of money spent on elections has
skyrocketed
the people of New Hampshire are acutely
aware of the huge amount of money spent
on political campaigns and of how so
much of it is coming from unknown
sources packs dark money and the very
wealthy
people are both discouraged and angry
they feel rightly so
that their voices are being overpowered
by big money
and so here you are today considering
house bill 324.
this bill takes its main structure from
an older bill Senate bill 304.
that bill was created by a working group
of six legislators
two senators four Representatives three
Republicans three Democrats
it was led by a moderator from open
democracy action
the process was long and hard and full
of discussions and compromises
the end result was a proposed public
Learning System that would have worked
for New Hampshire
House Bill 324 would also work for New
Hampshire today
it is a modest start
covering only the campaigns for governor
and executive Council
the goal is to show that such a such a
system can work and improve all our
election campaigns for New Hampshire
Public offices
one compelling future of the bill gives
each New Hampshire registered voter for
25 certificates to give to candidates of
their choice
the campaigns can exchange these
certificates for cash
the city of Seattle included this
feature when it adopted a Public Funding
funding system in 2015.
in evaluating the results of its Public
Funding initiative and the use of the 25
certificates two maps of the city were
created
the first showed where donors to
campaigns lived before the use of
certificates not surprisingly they were
clustered in wealthy sections of the
city
the second map after certificates were
in use showed donors spread all over the
city
people who had not been able to donate
to campaigns were empowered by these
certificates
also candidates needed to campaign all
over the city and reach out to all
neighborhoods in order to convince
voters to give them their certificates
the certificates created real Grassroots
campaigning
House Bill 324 deserves to be enacted
into law it creates a system of
financing public campaigns that is both
practical and innovative
the citizens of New Hampshire deserve to
move out of the wash of dark money from
unknown sources please vote ought to
pass
will you be taking questions from the
committee sure are there any questions
from the committee
seeing none thank you thank you um is
there anyone else who wishes to speak to
House Bill 324
seeing none I'm going to recess the
hearing so that we can re-notify it for
next week and have representative
Muirhead give his two cents so I'm
recessing House Bill the hearing on
House Bill 324 and I will be opening if
I find my sheet here I know it's 453.
I'll be opening the hearing for House
Bill 453
relative to prohibiting the folding of
election balance and providing adequate
envelopes for absentee ballots to
prevent folding see I'm awake now so I
um let me see here
I don't think I have a pink card for you
I'm sorry are you um
Perez yes I am okay representative Perez
thank you um in keeping in the past
precedence the way we will do these
hearings as we'll have the um obviously
the spots will introduce and then we'll
do the estate Representatives first
um and then after that we go through
this so representative Perez welcome to
election law thank you
good morning Mr Vice chair and committee
members um I am representative Christine
Perez
um thank you for allowing me to present
you House Bill 453 as amended and I have
copies of the amendment here
the bill as amended will only apply to
the 135 home towns and cities that as of
2022 used voting machines and will be
added to RSA 656 33 thus prohibiting
folded ballots
my initial concern with folded ballots
started working as a poll Challenger in
I observed paid staff of the Town
attempting to place absentee ballots
that had been folded into the voting
machines and frequently had difficulty
with the machines accepting these
ballots attempts to flatten the creases
were not always successful in gaining
access to the machines subsequently
after the 2020 election with the ballot
recounts in Windham the entire State and
Beyond became aware of the serious
folded pallet concerns
as you all know a vast majority of the
problem with these foldings was later
confirmed by the auditor
the concern over folded ballots
continues and it continues for other
reasons which I will go into with other
testimony
um items are regularly used now after
opening the envelopes and attempts to
flatten the creases this labor Sim
exercises exercise is not only con time
consuming but costly to the
municipalities that use paid voters
workers one must also note that not all
absentee ballots are mailed as
individually individually individuals
frequently go to the town offices and
hand in their balance
I present this as a bipartisan bill as
all towns and cities using folded
ballots have the potential for problems
I submit to you that this problem could
easily be resolved
by just not folding the ballots
I will leave further expertise to those
who have kindly offered to speak and
support to offer more insight into the
potential consequences
um one of I did learn late last night
that one very important
um individual that was going to testify
was unable to make it his name is Tom
Murray he is co-founder of the
government intended in Integrity project
so I would like to offer a little bit of
information because it is not just the
problem with the ballots being rejected
by the machines as was brought out
during the Wyndham recount the problem
of overvote and Phantom votes were also
brought out I have a copy of his report
that was filed with the commission on
voter confidence this past September of
2022. uh it's explains that overvote and
Phantom vote issues so an overvote we
all know if somebody puts too many names
if there's only supposed to pick four
and you pick five that's considered an
overvote what they found in Windham
would happen is very often the crease
would cause an overvote depending on
where that crease was
now
a lot of that that and that um
that can be found in his
um information on in the beginning
Phantom vote is when you have a folded
ballot and that fold goes through the
oval before a candidate's name and it
has been found and I have some pictures
of some folded ballots too it has been
found that actually
that fold can count as a vote towards
that particular candidate that can be
seen on the ballot and it's in testimony
here as they went on
the expected overvote rates were
expected with these machines to be about
.03 percent but in the seven towns that
this group went into further investigate
they were from 5.2 to
22.78 percent
their conclusion showed that some
changed elections House Bill 1163 that
was passed last year it was a start but
in his opinion and the people of this
group it is it is not all of that the
machines are not all of the machines are
capable what that bill did is it said
that if an overvote went into the
machine the machine would kick it out
so that it would then go be put into the
side of the machine I know that not all
the machines are capable of doing that
um
so that is his testimony as well
um I'm going to leave further expertise
to those who have kindly offered to
speak and support and offer more insight
into the potential consequences
but in conclusion committee members
voting is granted to us under article 11
of our state constitution Bills of Right
I firmly believe that the Integrity of
this right is a reasonable expectation
for all and I encourage you to
pass this Bill thank you will you be
taking questions yes I will are there
any questions from the committee
yes representative weary
Mr chair
um just a quick question
um suppose a folded ballot comes in
nonetheless what is there any
uh concern with how that will be
addressed or
I know that there are towns that have
been hand counting fold in ballots okay
um
that will be someone else will be going
into that as well but you know the the
point that I'm trying to make is that it
is three-fold it is not just going into
the machine it's the problem with that
with over count and then with this
phantom
are there questions from the committee
uh representative Howard uh thank you uh
so with the Secretary of State's office
looking at purchasing new voting
machines uh have you reached out to
their office at all to see if those new
machines uh would be able to uh count
the ballots with the the crease because
it seems uh that the current issue is
that the current uh machines cannot
count those ballots
well the current machines do can count
the ballots but not always accurately no
I in answer to your question no I have
not reached out to them
um there are the town that I live in
Londonderry actually for the March
upcoming March election we'll be using
um testing there's two towns I believe
that are doing it we'll be testing new
machines so that would be a good um
see test to see if something different
happens with them but no I have not
answered your question
other questions from the committee
yes representative Brennan
costly
folded ballots than what it would be to
provide the larger envelopes
no I'm telling you that I do not know
the answer to that and
um but again I think that is twofold
there's you are paying people to work at
the town so that is the larger
um the larger envelopes would be more
costly but to try to figure out exactly
how many of those will be used no I
don't I think the Integrity of your vote
may be another issue in along with the
um with the financial issues
thank you
um yes representative Lane
thank you I can't seem to reach my
uh what about the postage for the larger
envelopes so now we're going to have
voters having to spend more on postage
is that is that correct because I
honestly yes that would be correct but
that also I believe is going to be
brought up by people who know more about
it than I do all right thank you
yes representative
um Clayton um wood excuse me thank you
for taking my question do we know how
many uh potential uh ballots folded
ballots off her Town roughly well there
were over 62
um at the November election Statewide
Statewide yes okay thank you but that
was all all towns and cities this would
be
for the 135 that are using machines at
this time I understand thank you thank
you
other questions from the committee sixty
two thousand seven hundred and nine
representative thank you roughly thank
you representative Perez uh our own uh
The veneral Honorable representative
uh
sorry and representative Perez if you
could fill out the uh the pink card for
good morning thank you for that
introduction thank you for this
opportunity to speak this morning
I previously have been and I'm speaking
about in years past I have previously
opposed this measure because of the cost
involved to communities
and I've changed my mind and the reason
why is because I have new information my
I live in Derry and the town clerk she's
the former Town moderator told me that
she is spending time and money
to process folded ballots and this would
help alleviate some of that those
efforts that she's spending well when
she was our town moderator she's now our
Clerk
our absentee ballots were hand counted
in the last election because of concern
about absentee ballots going through the
machine I think we all know about the
situation that occurred in Windham where
there were the Phantom votes or the
votes that went through the uh the
bubble I'm sorry the fold went through
the bubble
um
and then the machines read that as a
vote for that candidate and then that
was a big mess
the community of Windham their Town
officials used some folding equipment
that
probably wasn't the best idea to use
because the folds that were pre-scored
on the ballots but in that spot
um
there was it was it was pre-scored to be
certain that there would be no fold on a
Target and then the officials in Windham
used some Machinery to to make the
process go faster and fold the the
ballots in a in a different way and it
ended up going through a Target and so
that was the problem there so
if there is the opportunity to
make voters more confident that this
will not occur again then that's a good
idea and if the communities are now
spending more money to either count them
by count absentee ballots by hand
then
um this is this is a good way to go and
also if also communities may may be
folding them differently than intended
or even the voter might might Fold It
innocently not realizing that this could
be an issue and also sometimes these
folds because they increase the
thickness of the paper in that spot can
cause some some
um jamming of the of the equipment and
then that becomes an issue as well and
whenever you have these problems voter
confidence gets
um becomes a concern because people are
always worried wait did my vote get
counted so
that's why our our election officials in
my community went to hand counting so
that those concerns would not be in play
and then that costs money because you
have to you have to um spend extra time
and hire staff for that
so someone asked a good question about
the postage and that's one of the
reasons why previously I would have said
no thank you to this bill
um
but everything's a balancing act isn't
it and we all we have to think
what concerns do we are more important
right here right now on this specific
bill
I think that um
the change on the postage when we have a
bill that would pertain to this coming
up in a few a little bit later today uh
I think right now a first class stamp is
59 cents and that is what an absentee
ballot folded would cost to send in and
now it's going to jump up higher I'm not
sure of that exact cost but I'm
guesstimating around a dollar fifty two
dollars on a flat
uh
envelope yeah
I know that's not ideal
and I like I said I would have opposed
this uh at these efforts for that reason
in the past
but I don't think that's unobtainable
for a voter and
a
we have to spend money on gas in
bringing these
um if we were to vote in person so you
know again Balancing Act what do we
worry about for the voters also voters
have the option of bringing these back
to the town hall when in the area that I
know I do that when I have something to
bring to town hall
and I want to save money on postage
because I'm cheap I mean Frugal I'm
frugal
all right well that's everything are
there any questions I hope I can get
those I hope I can answer those yes
representative Howard
thank you for taking my question uh so
as you would outlined uh in the Wyndham
uh audit situation the issue was the
folds on uh where the bubbles were would
it be cheaper to standardize folding
equipment than it would to uh offshore
offshift that cost onto the voter I'm
going to pause there Howard um Mr repson
hours there's no standardized folding
equipment in the state of New Hampshire
just so you know
yes I I'm sorry I'm trying to uh ask if
it would be cheaper uh to implement that
as a one-time cost rather than it's a
fair question I just want to make sure
you understand that there's no
designated folding yes I I was asking if
it would be cheaper to implement that
equipment thank you for that question
I was curious about where
all those pre-scored
folds landed and I looked at each and
every ballot
in the state of New Hampshire that year
that that problem occurred in Windham
and the Secretary of State's office does
pay attention to that very closely and
the preschools are never in a spot where
they would hit a voting Target a bubble
so that they would be in between a name
on on the ballots that so what happened
in Windham is they didn't fold the votes
in that manner I mean the ballots in
that manner and the um
they used other folding equipment that
they should not have done but they were
trying to save time so because we had so
many absentee ballots that year with the
pandemic so that's
the problem that occurred there and I
think someone else will be speaking
about that in much more detail behind me
we have never talked about folded
ballots in this committee ever right now
other questions from the committee
representative Hamer
thank you for taking my question I have
a question how many envelopes would be
required for sending out the ballot
and the weight of that
right well I'm sure the the efforts
would be made to keep the weight as low
as possible not using thick paper uh
there's the ballot it would be the same
as it is now
um
think of that's two or three uh the
Secretary of State's office could
address that issue but it would be the
same you'd have the ballot to send back
in and then the ballot inside that I
mean the envelope to send back in and
then the ballot inside that envelope so
I think it would be the same envelope
okay thank you
no worries uh yes representative Lane
thank you Mr chair and thank you
I just lost my train of thought
if it comes back to me okay I'll return
absolutely all right other other not
questions from the committee
all right representative Lane I think
you're going to be uh you're gonna have
to fire that uh missile off later
I thank you representative good home
O'Brien uh next up representative Erica
oh okay um well we can we if you want to
if you want to ask right now I'm fine
you're not done yet we're gonna we're
gonna extend some courtesy here she she
remembered uh representative Lane
what's what's the amendment change from
I'm not sure that uh I have the answer
to that okay I think it was distributed
I I was trying to compare it but it's
coming up the answer is coming up it was
distributed I believe uh obviously I'll
all right now representative Erica
welcome to uh welcome to election law uh
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
election law committee um to answer that
question from representative Lane the
amendment says that it's not all towns
and cities it's simply those who use
vote counting machines so that we don't
add an extra cost to those towns who are
already on Counting every ballot
you're welcome
um I came to this topic from a slightly
different different approach but we had
one of those wonderful matchmaking by
OLS opportunities so I am a co-sponsor
to this bill from my colleague from
Londonderry I had looked at the ballot
in Derry there was actually no way to
fold derry's ballot without going
through a bubble on one side or the
other it was unfortunately one of the
scenarios where the Secretary of State
simply could not give a space I looked
at how we might mandate that there's
certain spaces for folding what we might
be able to do in order to make sure that
we avoid this problem while keeping
these ballots in a small an envelope as
possible
I couldn't come up with any solution
nobody could come up with any solution
to make sure that this wouldn't happen
and that's actually why we had poll
workers were counting until about 3 A.M
in Derry this past November
we had over 1 000 ballots that were
absentee and were folded because any
fold went through one of the bubbles
it was very very important to make sure
with confidence that the election
results were actually true a thousand
votes would have been enough to swing
quite a few elections in Derry so that
was absolutely mandatory to make sure
that we were confident
that cost a lot of money it cost a lot
of time and if we didn't have such an
exceptional town clerk it would have
thrown a lot into question people know
how seriously she takes election
integrity and therefore any concerns
were diffused with going so late Into
the Night
by requiring absentee ballots to being
closed in an envelopes that will allow
the ballot to be mailed without folding
we remove that risk and we remove that
decision from town Town moderators who
may be facing a shortage of poll workers
we need our poll workers to be on point
all day and hopefully not all night
until it's almost Sunrise again that's
what was expected of our poll workers
and we need to figure out what we can do
in order to ease their burden so we have
people continue to volunteer at our
elections and keep our elections fair
well when we look at this I look at the
cost and I look at the cost to a person
who has to return these ballots right
now a forever stamp is 63 cents and an
oversized letter is a dollar three we're
talking about an extra 40 cents if we're
looking at extra overweight charges then
we get into another territory as well
but I ask you what's the value in making
sure that your vote is counted correctly
if you're sending in an absentee ballot
that's folded and you're not sure if the
machine will read it correctly or if a
poll worker counting at 2 30 in the
morning is going to read it correctly is
it worth 40 cents is it worth a dollar
we okay questions from the committee
uh representative Bell
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking the question
so do you think this should be on our
show this Friday you don't have to
answer that's a plug
other questions from the committee
representative Burnham did I put out
your name right Burnham or Burnham
Burnham is fine thank you thank you uh
Mr chair and thank you rep
resent um as far as the
suggested new envelope would that just
be us is there a standardized envelope
where there'll be a specialty envelope
or just a regular Manila size
um thank you for the question that gets
into the issue of our length of ballots
when you have 10 representatives in
Derry plus all the other office offices
we have a rather large ballot that will
require
um that will require probably some work
to figure out the correct way to get
that done I do think that this is
important enough that we need to figure
out how to do that and how to move
forward on this because confidence is
key otherwise people become
disenfranchised because they don't think
their vote counts
thank you other questions from the
committee
um yes representative Brennan
thank you for taking my question
um in the spirit of ensuring that every
vote is counted
how do we address the additional
shipping time for these larger envelopes
that cost between 125 and 175 per ballot
um thank you I actually found the
oversized postage for oversized letter
as a dollar three on the USPS site today
but yours probably works if you end up
sticking a few more envelopes in there
may be more shipping time but when you
request an absentee ballot you know that
there's going to be some time at the
post office I know in in towns that are
further away that may need to send into
a Central Station that's a lot further
away than Dairy and Manchester the
turnaround time may be slower but I
think that that's a function that people
in a town would understand how long mail
delivery takes this does not stop people
from taking their absentee ballot into
town hall and delivering it just as they
would that would save them that money it
would give them that confidence that
it's actually in election officials
hands and there's nothing to prohibit
that and honestly if anybody's mailing
even a standard size envelope or a large
one with the way things are nowadays I
wouldn't mail it in the last week
anyways
other questions from the committee
saying none thank you representative
Leon thank you next up representative
well I'm mostly here for the next one
but
um I I discovered some things while
researching my testimony that relate to
this bill so I'm reluctantly opposed to
it
yeah I definitely agree that what
happened in Windham was a fiasco
um but I
I still think voting machines are
capable of reading folded ballots
um and the big problem with this is um
we're talking about these postage for
for envelopes so my um first class uh
envelopes actually the size limit for
standard size first class is 6 1 8
inches by 11 and a half inches which is
obviously much uh smaller than uh
smaller than a than a ballot and that's
the type of mail which the forever
stamps I think they're currently 63
cents with 24 for each additional
allowance um
if
so if you uh but these will probably but
then there's also the large envelope
rate which is uh only goes up to
uh 15 inches by 11 and 5 8 inches of
size 11 and 5 8 is enough to accommodate
the width of our ballots but I
and I wish the and you might have to
check for the Secretary of State's
office who seemed not to be here but I
think some ballots are currently more
than 15 inches in size so you
unless you want to put something in
there limiting the size of pallets they
need to get more multi-page ballots and
uh you know it's a simple seemingly
simple thing that
um as cascading consequences so I I
would say the best solution the best
solution is uh best solution is just to
continue folding the ballads probably
maybe using a slightly larger what we
call it digest size envelope that
requires maybe only two folds instead of
some people end up sending things in
especially of a letter size return
envelope but that's uh folded it four or
eights I've seen some very elaborately
folded ballots what observing counts
some
and uh the other thing is of course to
bear in mind is you have the affidavitum
you have like
you have to put the ballot inside when
you return it there's at least two
return ballots you have to you have like
that
like I think it's called the affidavit
ballot that you sign and then you put
that aside the actual mailing envelope
and then occasionally people then stick
the mailing envelope inside a second
melee envelope and if so if you're
talking like a really big flat that's uh
those are envelopes that people will
have a hard time
those are that are expensive to provide
and if uh it's also something that if
they want to use a additional mailing
envelope especially if they're overseas
voters whatever that might not be
something that they even find where they
are so I would
I would reluctantly say that we we
should keep this part of the election
law the way it is and just uh you know
improve our voting uh our voting
procedures because I don't think there's
any way prevent at least some ballots
from coming in with folds in them for
one reason or another so
um
I agree that we agree there's a problem
but I'm not sure this would create more
solutions especially with balance that
are bigger than that large envelope size
then you get for priority mail which is
really expensive that's like 9.95 a pop
and that's uh
that's an unreasonable burden to put on
uh on the voters and
also if the other
also then if the state pays for return
postage as in the next bill then that's
an unreasonable burden to put on the
state so I I would in principles of
principle it's a good idea but I don't
think it's going to work unless you
restrict the size of the of the ballots
um so that's that's my uh that's my
that's my testimony so I'd be happy to
take any questions should anyone have
one I not that I can necessarily answer
them but I'd be happy to take the
questions questions from the committee
seeing none uh good thank you uh
representative you'll be disappointed
the Secretary of State's office is here
and they are up next oh oh no I'm not
disappointed okay so if I'm if I'm wrong
um I stand corrected if I'm right well
all right we're back sorry about that
um
uh senior senior Deputy
um Hennessy correct or did I get your
title just deputy just Deputy I
apologize thank you Mr chair uh thank
you members of the committee I am here
to offer just some education some
information on the envelopes and ballot
um the process for absentee envelopes is
that the secretary's estate's office for
All State elections mails out to your
local city or town clerk uh three
envelopes one would be the outside
envelope that the clerk puts all of the
voter information into
um the other would be the return outside
envelope which the voter would put their
affidavits signed affidavit envelope
into which inside goes their absentee
ballot so you have a big envelope with a
medium-sized envelope with a smaller
envelope with a ballot ultimately is is
the way that would work
um I I did hear from the sponsor of the
bill that she is planning on submitting
an amendment to remove hand count Town
ballots if you are from a handcount town
you know that your ballot is always
folded
um some of this has to do with privacy
concerns so
um voters are required to hand their
ballot to the moderator and the
moderator puts it into the box so voters
like to make sure that nobody can see
their ballot and how they voted so
that's one of the reasons why Hancock
time ballots are folded but if the
amendment removes that then we don't
need to talk about these anymore
there are three other styles or sizes of
ballots to consider and ideally all
ballots would be just printed on one
side of the ballot because again voters
like the option of turning their ballot
over when it goes through a machine
count so that the moderator or anyone
else hanging out by the machine doesn't
see how they voted so in a smaller town
in a smaller election year you might
just have an eight and a half by eleven
ballot
um in a bigger Town
um that has a lot of State reps you
would have an eight and a half by 14
ballot
and then in a bigger town with a lot of
State reps and perhaps maybe a lot of
other candidates on the ballot you would
have an eight and a half by 18 ballot
so
um if you think about the process and
that this Bill calls for where a voter
would or anyone wouldn't be able to vote
about fold a ballot and it would require
some sort of rigid envelope and I think
the easiest way would be the affidavit
envelope would have to be rigid since
that would be the most inside envelope
to protect the ballot so if you have a
big ballot the Virgin envelope would
have to go around this one here and then
there would have to be a bigger envelope
to be able to fit this envelope inside
and then the third envelope would again
have to be bigger to fit this ballot the
other two envelopes inside of it
um just because of time constraints we
weren't able to have a sit-down meeting
with the post office to determine what
that might look like what the envelope
options are with a different vendor too
but um
this if you if you again just visualize
what a voter would get in their mailbox
this probably would not actually even
fit in their mailbox if it was rigid and
not being able to bend
um even
an envelope like this which would have
um an envelope that would fit this
inside to not Bend and then two other
bigger envelopes may not fit in a a
voter's mailbox either
um so those are just some things to
consider with trying not to fold the
ballot
um
I think that's what I have for you right
now so I'm happy to take any questions
that you might have
all right and I'm sorry did I introduce
myself Aaron Hennessey deputy secretary
of state I attempted to introduce you
and I bundled it uh uh marvelously
representative boam
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the question uh with the current
voting machines and the newer ones
will it will it be capable of handling
ballots that are smaller
then what the voters are using in other
words smaller absentee ballots then
then the regular ballot
so are you saying that perhaps a smaller
ballot than an eight and a half by
eleven I think what you get down to at
that point would be that the voter
wouldn't be able to see the candidates
names
or voters that
like me have eye issues but I I can find
out about the sizes that their their
mailing I mean once a month I get an
envelope about this thick from the post
office for my County
um
ballot uh at least once a month and it
comes in a couple days so I don't think
the the late problem but I do see
do you I mean you already mentioned you
haven't looked into
what the maximum size envelopes the post
I'm sure that for any price you're able
to send it but it being rigid
um the post office does note on their
website that you might have to pay
parcel package prices for that which if
you've tried to mail
holiday packages recently you know that
that's very expensive
further questions uh representative
Howard
thank you Mr chair and uh thank you for
taking my question uh so I'll I'll
repeat uh what I asked uh the sponsor of
the bill earlier uh and for the new
voting machines that the Secretary of
State's office is looking at uh have the
capabilities and accuracies of the
machines been tested on if they can
count uh with potential folds on uh
where the uh Circle uh to select who you
want uh would be
thank you for the question so
just for some background information the
ballot law commission is the one that
excuse me and in the general election
there were three towns that tried out a
new device from voting works
and in our post audits of that general
election we didn't encounter any issues
where there was any
um unintended marks counted by the
device
there are three other devices that may
be used in these in the local elections
this winter in towns and cities those
are dominion esns and if a town decides
to sponsor it clear ballot and after all
of those elections are done we will also
be doing audits of the voters intent and
if the ballot and if the device read
that ballot correctly so we haven't gone
through the process of making sure that
what happened in Windham when they
folded their ballots through the oval
wouldn't happen again on the new more
sophisticated devices but our our hope
further questions representative Brennan
thank you for taking my question the the
current absentee ballots when they're
mailed out are they able to is a voter
able to Simply put that ballot in their
standard mailbox and have it picked up
by their regular mail carrier
yes as long as they put postage on it
are the questions representative weary
thank you Mr chair
um
thank you for taking my question
do we know the distribution or the
breakdown between those ballots which
are handed in for absentee purposes in
the town halls versus what is actually
mailed I thank you for the question
that's a good question I don't believe
there's any tracking mechanism for how
it was delivered
right now I don't believe any towns
track that
and it's not I don't believe it's in our
and our system to do that
a way to calculate that just so you know
would be we passed a law last year for
um making Epstein data public and you'd
look for people that requested and
returned on the same day
because there's no way the post office
seeing none thank you deputy secretary
ah thank you thanks for taking my
testimony my name is Louise Spencer I'm
co-founder of an all-volunteer
Grassroots advocacy organization called
the Kent Street Coalition
um but I'm speaking today on my own
behalf
um and I am speaking in opposition to
this bill
um I want to just first address the
issue of the folding of the ballots and
the issue that occurred in Windham that
was a very unique circumstance in that a
machine was used to fold and crease the
ballots and what happened was that the
process of using that very heavy
stamping machine to create the crease
created a shadow line that unfortunately
as we saw did lead to Phantom ballots
and Phantom votes and also over votes so
that was a function of a folding machine
being used
Windham this last election did a trial
of hand folded ballots before the
election to see if any of those would
just by doing a regular hand folding if
we would see Phantom votes are over
votes
that did not occur none of the
hand-folded ballots regardless of where
they where the fold landed
made a impacted the the vote so I just
think it's very important to be aware
that that was a very unique situation in
Windham and that it could be addressed
by just not allowing these sorts of
machines to be used in the future and
certainly windham's not using them
so
um
then there's the issue about the
envelopes themselves that would be used
we're not just talking about being able
to go to Staples and buy envelopes to do
this these envelopes have to be of a
certain quality and they have to be
pre-printed with specific information
so there's a real cost in in the
I would point you to the committee the
the secretary of state had a special
committee on covid voting that covered a
lot of issues but I would say that 50
percent of the maybe eight meetings that
they had to talk about how to address
elections through covid had to do
specifically with the absentee ballots
knowing there would be any increased use
of them they found that the cost was
prohibitive to using this sort of
um to doing flat ballots
and so
there's lots of research there I can
pull it up for you if anyone's
interested it's all on the record hours
and hours and hours of time were spent I
sat through through all of it and even
though I originally thought this might
be a way to go it it just seemed like a
real obstacle so next you know the we do
have the issue of the slower mail that
we're facing all around
but this would add another
slow down to the process as I think you
mentioned
and that's both we have to remember on
the sending end from the town to the
voter and then on the voter end
this also is an issue when you come to
yukava voters who are overseas and these
ballots have to be sent overseas again a
really increased cost particularly when
you're looking at larger envelopes
and heavier weights perhaps so you know
for the state even if they're not
picking up the cost of the postage
there's still a substantial increase of
cost
and then let's look at the voter this
this presents real costs to them and a
burden on their voting access partly
it's the delay time that it would now
take extra days to
um
to make sure that their vote could be
processed and let's remember that the
majority of people who do absentee
ballots do them because they're not able
to get down to the town halls to deliver
their ballots they're out of town
they're out of state they're disabled
so you know it's not an option of I
don't want to pay that postage so I'm
going to go down to the town hall or I
don't I'm worried about the time and
will my ballot be counted so I'm going
to go down to town hall these absentee
ballot Provisions in our constitution
exist primarily to accommodate the
people who are really not able to to be
there and get their ballots in like that
so and then the cost is real for people
I mean we hear a lot of talk about you
know the cost of
living has gone way up and
those extra 50 cents in fact can make a
difference particularly if you have
multiple members in your family who are
voting absentee so I think it's it's not
it doesn't behoove us to
um
to downgrade that concern and then it's
not clear to me from the way the bill is
written whether the voter themselves
would in fact be subject to a penalty if
they did think oh I'm going to say
Postage and I'm going to get a regular
envelope and fold it and send it in that
of course would be very disconcerting if
that was the case
um
so I just double checking the other
issue around yuakava quite frankly is
with uh SB 418 which already has
presented
um timeline burdens around primary
elections for whether the state is going
to be able to get ballots to our
overseas military and other overseas
voters
in time to meet the requirements of
uacava if we are now adding extra days
because we have a flat rate envelope
that needs to go out and that slows the
process we're running into additional
problems with SB 418 so with that I will
conclude my um my testimony I'm happy to
take any questions
questions from the committee
good morning
uh my name is Ken eyring I'm from
Windham
and I appreciate the time to speak on
this bill I'm in favor of this bill I
lived through the nightmare of the
election the general election in 2020. I
believe that this should be a bipartisan
bill
um I work very closely with former
Secretary of State Bill Gardner and
Senator Bob Guida to get the forensic
audit that would analyze what took place
in Windham that was the
largest numerical discrepancy in the
history of the state between election
day results and the Hand recount
and
the forensic audit which was led by
Harry hirsty who has been a consultant
for New Hampshire
in the past he confirmed in that audit
that folds going through ovals can be
misread and are misread by the machines
and it was a rate from anywhere from 35
percent and upwards to almost double
so you've heard testimony that folded
ballots going through machines that can
be read
accurately
but a folded ballot and a folded but
then a fold going through an oval
through a ballot or two different things
and we have human error that can be
introduced and it is introduced in every
election
in Windham in the November 2020 election
between the election day results and the
1163 votes were shifted they were
adjusted
too accurate to more accurately reflect
what the voter's intent were
1163 votes is a lot of votes that were
inaccurately counted by the machines on
so
I believe that if ballots are continued
to be folded
then it should be mandatory that they'd
be hand counted
so last year HB 1163
addressed part of the issue of the
Windham incident
the general election in 2020.
by
having the machine set to reject over
voted ballots
so what was happening is that in races
where there were all of the votes for
any given race
were filled in for any given for all the
candidates if an oval went through one
of the candidates
ovals that were not voted for
and it was read as a as a phantom vote
then it triggered an overvote and if you
look at the testimony that Tom Murray
presented that the sponsor
said that she distributed to each of you
I think you'll see that there were
enormous issues with
overvotes being counted
in towns that use machines all across
New Hampshire
um
but 1163 does not address the fact that
there are still
Phantom votes that can be counted and in
the November 2020 general election in
Windham one of the Democrats candidates
received 99 extra votes that were
removed from her vote totals during the
recount and also confirmed during the
forensic audit
so this bill would address that part of
the problem
and lead to more accurate results
uh the ballot there was a question
raised about uh testing on the new
machines that are being looked at I sat
in uh on
a ballot law
Commission test of two machines
and they
did not put any folded ballots through
the Dominion machine that they tested
zero
that to me is disturbing knowing the
fact of the issues that we've had with
folded ballots
they put two folded ballots through the
voting Works machines
and again that's not enough
to make a statement that we have
accurate ability to read folded ballots
through ovals through any new machines
you heard testimony that Wyndham did a
test and that there were no problems
with the folds going through
with with folded ballots but again
you need to test with folds going
through the ovals
and since Windom is been brought up I
want to
emphasize the fact that there is always
a human error
and you would think that the town that
brought such
attention to this issue regarding the
November 2020 general election would be
extremely careful
with how they process their folded
they still folded ballots through the
ovals
for the September 13th primary and I
find that to be very disturbing
and I have you know I didn't think of it
I should have brought a sample of that I
filed a complaint with 33 issues
regarding Wyndham's elections for the
September primary I'm going to file
another complaint
for the general election
and I'd be happy to
forward a link to all of you in this
committee so that you can read that
complaint and one of the links in that
complaint shows the folded
uh ballot that goes through two ovals
which again is very disturbing
Dairy hand counts all of the
all of the folded ballots I think that
is an exemplary example
um
if you pass this bill there will be a
tremendous savings for towns that do
that but what Dairy does is it ensures
the accuracy of the vote and isn't that
what we all want we all want to make
sure that every valid vote cast is
counted
accurately
um
you know from my position every Phantom
vote that's counted
disenfranchises an actual vote
and
uh you know there was concerns about the
size of the envelopes we all get mail
all of us get mail that's larger than an
eight and a half by eleven
piece of paper
the post the postman folds it around our
other envelopes and puts it in our
mailbox
there's no Bend in here that's going to
mess up how our machine rate reads the
vote
if that's if that's how it was delivered
but if that's a concern and it causes
you not to support this bill then again
I would suggest that somebody write an
amendment that says that all bolded
ballots should be hand counted or must
be hand counted you know the the cost
of
the extra envelopes I realize that's a
consideration
but in the end that's the foundation of
our government we want to make sure that
however the votes are cast that they're
accurately counted and
the as you heard testimony from
representative Lyon uh isn't it there's
an enormous cost to Dairy right now and
other towns who hand count
folded ballots so that would be offset
and it would be a tremendous
reduction in the burden of those towns
because they stay until all the wee
hours in the morning counting the
ballots to make sure that the votes are
accurately counted and I know from
testifying on other bills there are
concerns about
extending you know putting requirements
on Election workers that extend their
hours into the wee hours in the morning
because the longer that they stay there
you know the more that there might be a
possibility that errors are made because
again human error people get tired
so you know in conclusion I I
respectfully ask that you support this
bill because I've lived through the
Nightmare and and in addition to that
the same error was made on subsequent
elections so I appreciate your time
foreign thank you are there questions
from the committee
representative Burnham
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr erling
has there been any consideration I know
we've talked about envelopes folding has
there been any consideration on mailing
tubes it seems like the standard of
um the ballots in width is eight and a
half inches so that would give a
reusable mailing tube an option to not
only not have a fold in it but you to be
reused as the voter sends back their
ballot I I had never thought of that but
I actually think that's a clever
um and a very insightful suggestion I
don't know what the cost would be but
the cost would be more upfront obviously
and then as you suggested you could
recycle the tubes because to be returned
back to the town I think that's a good
idea something to look into but but it
would help Implement something like this
and address some of the concerns
thank you
all right thank you thank you for your
time
representative wood can you send up the
foreign
one person signed in for and against not
sure what that means and then two in
favor of the bill and that closes the
she might be the one that has I don't
have a card
that one with no name I have a car I
have a blank card
foreign
I have a card that says simply watch
questions one minute there's no name or
okay and it's unusual but we will reopen
the public hearings on our house bill
453.
I'll be quick Joan dargie
um town clerk Milford also the
legislative chair for um co-chair for
New Hampshire City and town clerks
Association
um one of the things I'm just going to
bring up what hasn't been addressed and
that is the cost to the towns because
the town has to create their own
affidavit envelope
if you picture that the quantity of
affidavit envelopes that changes every
time the affidavit envelope changes
um that we wouldn't have the the volume
that would for that size envelope it'll
cut it'd be cost prohibited basically to
come up with an eight and a half by 14
and and the other thing we have to
figure is like in Milford our ballots
are 10 to 12 pages long
so for a town election which I'm
assuming this would apply to the town
election as well it's not going to apply
to it
okay so it should apply to I mean I'm
assuming it applies to the town election
so we wouldn't be able to fold the town
ballots the reason that I did a the the
city and town clerks Association was
split
so we have towns like Derry that want to
hand count the absentees but then we
have other towns that have four to ten
thousand absentee ballots there's no way
they're going to hand count them
um the what we did have I'll just bring
up what we had as for a suggested
Amendment and that is a one-fold
just folding in half that may make the
envelopes more
amenable to producing and in the postage
wouldn't be so cost prohibitive
um and then the other amendment was to
exclude the towns from this requirement
and that's all I have so sorry about not
filling out the card properly
that's okay and we will need one though
when you go back
excuse me we will need you to fill one
out though we'll do thank you thank you
uh no I don't think we're gonna do that
because we're significantly over time
and I'm probably gonna get chewed out by
the clerk for opening and closing a
and the public hearing on House Bill 453
okay
public hearing on House Bill 508 is open
I'm Jonah wheeler I'm represent
Peterborough and Sharon Hillsboro
District 33.
um like I said I'll be as quick as I can
I think I will be this is a pretty
simple piece of legislation even though
I am a freshman with a fiscal Note
coming before you I think it is fairly
simple and straightforward
we've had poll taxes in this country for
a long time and states have employed
poll taxes other countries have employed
poll taxes and I think the evidence is
pretty clear that those poll taxes
hinder people's ability to get out there
and vote not uh everyone people who can
afford them are able to vote but those
who are not cannot access their rights
as a citizen to vote and participate in
their governmental process the 24th
Amendment ratified in 1964
made it illegal for poll taxes to exist
in federal elections but as we all
probably know the state still has the
ability to impose a poll tax if it if
it's so wanted to so I'm bringing this
legislation forward to try and uh Nix
that before before it happens
um
like Louise Spencer said for the last
piece of legislation the cost of living
has increased uh significantly we all I
think feel that in one way or another
and while the
price of a stamp might not seem like a
lot 40 cents to a dollar to to many of
us that can be a lot for some people it
can be a burden nonetheless it's a
financial burden to voting no matter how
much it is and with the cost of living
and with people who generally vote again
like Louise said in her in her testimony
people who are using absentee ballots
are people who have disabilities or
health concerns and have a hard time
getting to the town clerk's office to
access their absentee ballot in the
first place so why would we add another
barrier to make it so that they have to
to grab a stamp I think this is a
worthwhile expenditure for the state and
voting for your voting should be your
right as a citizen uh not a privilege to
those who can afford it so with that
I'll I'll take any questions that the
committee has and I thank the chairman
for for allowing me to speak thank you
questions
I guess you've supplied everything they
well I
he set me up it was my fault
representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you
committee members for allowing me to
speak as representative wheeler did I am
going to take the same tact and let
y'all get to lunch just make it really
brief
um no matter where one happens to be on
the political Spectrum uh chances are
you believe in the value of democracy of
people's participation ability to
participate in our electoral process
I believe that that necessarily entails
um ensuring uh excessive accessibility
for all facilitating safe and secure
elections with input from as many of our
citizens as possible in that light this
bill helps to reduce barriers to
participation plain and simple really
the only concern I can see is a cost and
to that I say if anything is worth
investing in it is our fundamental right
to participation in our electoral
process
told you I was going to keep it short
and sweet
and I'm open to any questions thank you
any questions
well done thank you
is there Joan dargie oh okay
paper
town of Milford town clerk New Hampshire
City and town clerks Association on this
one where also just have a question as
to whether it is going to apply to the
a really good question to ask the bill
sponsor okay rather than the committee
okay and that's where we're mixed on it
in favor and not in favor I'm sorry what
that's where we're mixed the
associations mixed on that can't really
vote on it without understanding that
thank you very much Mr chair I'm
continue to be representative Timothy
Horgan I continue unless something
unexpected has happened I continue to
represent Stratford County District 10
the town of Durham so I actually have a
page of written testimony which um
I think I already submitted it on the
web portal but um here's a hard copy of
it
and um as a others have noted uh the
current system we allow we expect uh
voters to fix their own Tamp stamps to
the absentee ballot return envelopes and
I admit this is in line with the New
Hampshire way of doing things where
government does as little as possible
for the people and the government does
anything it does to as cheaply as
possible but I uh don't think that's
fair as I I would agree that it's a poll
tax but also there's a practical issue
not everybody has a supply of stamps
around the house even those who I mean
I've got lots of those stamps around the
house but those forever stamps currently
worth 63 cents don't necessarily have a
posted scale to make sure the returned
envelope weighs less than an ounce nor
does anybody have nor do most people nor
is everyone necessarily have a supply of
additional out stamps currently 24 cents
per additional ounce of the package
weighs more than an ounce and ballot
return envelopes often way more than one
ounce and
it would be a good fraction for Town
clerks to actually uh
CR make up a sample of returned envelope
ballot and weigh it I don't know whether
they all do it and also sometimes the
cost will vary a little bit uh
according to perhaps like say whether as
I alluded to sometimes people put a
second their own mailing envelope around
the official mailing envelope especially
when this sentient from uh from overseas
um so that's uh which might which would
make it way which might kick an envelope
up to the next ounce but anyway
um we had a lot of discussion about the
size of ballast in the previous bill um
and we mentioned those uh
first class large envelopes those are
light Flats they probably be a fairly
lightweight flat unless you're from
Milford in which case you've got 12
pages of stuff in the uh in the ballot
and those we've had a problem
this isn't really really easy to build
but those will actually have the uh
calendars mailed are having a problem
getting the calendars is taking a week
and that's because the post office has
to separately hand
usually as stupid has to hand sort the
very the lighter large envelope so
that's that's why that piece is taking a
week to get there instead of two days
and that would happen with certain
ballots depending on what the size of
the package was but and finally I go
into some detail
I have a couple paragraph about the
possibility of the Secretary State
getting a business
plymail account so that'll be a
so it'd be a simple way to pay for the
uh at least I think it would be simple
I'm sure there's some complications from
overlooked of of
to send the ballots back otherwise
otherwise the alternative would be to
have the town clerks uh you know keep
hand over the stamps to the uh to the
citizens they come and return the ballot
if they're or if they're mailing out one
that's I think
and actually I probably maybe I should
have done this because this actually uh
kicks up the cost in the financial note
because there's an annual fee for such
an account but uh it would I still think
that would be money well worth it and
it's not a not really a large sum of
money in the larger schema things in
fact can probably be paid for entirely
out of the existing uh so-called Java
funds help America vote tax funds so I
I would say this is a uh excellent bill
it's a common sense idea that should
have been done years ago so I uh urgency
committees move forward and pass it
and I guess I'd be happy to take any
questions although I am I too like the
previous
um Witnesses M standing between you and
your lunch but anyway thank you thank
you very much
questions from the committee
representative Kennedy
thank you
um do you believe that every person who
votes in person should receive a mileage
reimbursement for driving to the polling
place no
I mean
I mean if you wish I don't know whether
that be a Germaine amendment to this
bill you're certainly free to consider
that if you think that's a good idea but
I would say
I would say no but there's I don't think
a mileage reimbursement is the same
thing as uh providing return postage on
the envelope so it's
thank you I mean I would probably put in
for the mileage and take it if you if
further questions from the committee
Deputy deputy secretary Hennessey
foreign
again Aaron Hennessey I'm the deputy
secretary of state and I'm just here to
answer any questions you might have and
point out that this bill which is under
657.7 would apply to State elections
only
so people who request an absentee ballot
in a town or city election would have to
and with that you're done
okay
one
two three signed in favor and none
opposed that closes the public hearing
on House Bill 508.
and the committee is in recess until one
o'clock
foreign
okay the average of the clocks that I
checked agreeing on one o'clock we will
open the public hearing on House Bill
195. welcome representative Lane
welcome
um 195 I okay I'm Connie Lane I'm
represent uh Ward 2 in Concord and
um thank you
this is a campaign finance bill the
theory is is that the transparency is
the goal so that the voter knows who is
sending them
communication whether that communication
is email
Flyers that we all get inundated with
or any other communication
this bill has been around for a while as
you can see and the report that we just
got and
um it it is lowering the threshold from
five thousand dollars to twenty five
hundred dollars in order to qualify for
registration as a political advocacy
organization under RSA 664.
so if an organization sends out mailers
emails tv ads within 60 days before a
primary or a general election that costs
more than twenty five hundred dollars
they must register with the Secretary of
State as a political
advocacy organization and that in a
nutshell is what this bill is about
there are some concerns that it is
perhaps unconstitutional but all it does
really is expand this
to
those who are sending us and not and we
don't know who they are sending us
information either about candidates or
issues and it lowers that to twenty five
hundred dollars
with that
thank you representative Blaine do you
have an example of a group that will be
affected by this
I'm sorry could you set up an example of
a group that would be affected by this
no because right now they don't register
so we don't know who they are they don't
even have to put their stuff on their
mailers
and I'll allow myself a follow-up
it's good to be the chair sometimes
um so and it's twenty five hundred
dollars in total yes
over what period of time or per camera
if they do it within 60 days if they
mail that out and that within that 60
days they spent 2500 then they are
political advocacy organization and they
have to register all we're requiring is
that they register so that people know
where it's coming from
thank you
further questions
representative Barry I just want to tack
onto that um so it's 60 days or a
calendar year correct
because it's tacking into the existing
or am I misreading it
because it's I don't want to read the
whole thing but Pao means identity
including an unlimited to an
organization describing I said well that
makes our expenditures of 2500 or more
in a calendar year so it's 60 days or
calendars or or more you're right in a
calendar year okay so it's it's the 60
days and the calendar year yes okay yeah
I was I wasn't trying to correct you I
apologize I was just genuinely
curious
representative wary
thank you Mr chair uh thank you
representative Lane
um so does this dog just Barker does it
have any teeth or is it
it it's just informing the public of
where they're receiving this it doesn't
do anything for enforcement or any no
anything any already whatever
enforcement is there already would not
change so right now okay and actually
there's not a lot of enforcement but
we're trying to give you know baby steps
follow up good so is there is this
happening now with the 5000 limit no
because it doesn't expand out to those
kinds of mailers and things so we've
expanded the definition so that these
they can't come in and dump for instance
something that says I have a position on
something and I don't have a position on
that it's contrary and it comes out two
weeks before the election I have no time
or money to counter that so the idea is
to pry at least people will know who
sent out that mailer that's the goal
representative Bay
the 2500 is that like if it's a mailer
is it one mailing or total for mailing
for different total thank you it's 25
like I think representative Berry
pointed out it's gonna be a total of
twenty five hundred dollars in a year
but only if they send it out within that
representative Barry so I just um just
want to go back to it because you and I
had a discussion about paos
um so basically we're lowering you're
attempting to lower the threshold five
thousand twenty five hundred and then
you're expanding the definition of what
a let's call it political communication
further questions
thank you representative Blaine
good afternoon the committee this is my
2022 political mail pile
and I just wanted to show you that
disclosure
is different on almost every single one
of these pieces whether they follow the
law or not follow the law some have paid
for by the name of the committee but not
their Treasurer some have no disclosure
at all
some have registered some have not so
they send out mail when they have no
marking on them you don't know who it's
from but some of them have markings on
them some of this mail is federal and
some of its state so
I know that this will only apply to the
state but open democracy let me my name
is Olivia Zink and I'm from Franklin New
Hampshire and I'm the executive director
of open democracy action we're a
nonpartisan non-profit
um here in Concord we've been working on
transparency for a really long time so
what this bill does is if you're
spending money and naming a candidate
you have to register and report your
campaign Finance
so it it basically strikes the language
functionally equivalent to express
advocacy and if people don't know what
um Bill Marsh doesn't talk about his
record on the environment because it's
extreme it's not saying vote against him
it's just sort of stating something
about this state Senate candidate if you
use the magic word vote for vote against
there's three or four other magic words
that trigger you to
be considered a functionally equivalent
to express advocacy but if you don't use
call your State Rep and ask them to to
for this position and then you actually
don't trigger disclosure voters see all
of this as political mail
voters don't distinction don't make a
distinction between something that says
you know Bill Marsh doesn't talk about
his record on health care and vote for
vote against
this bill closes a loophole in our
campaign Finance
many years ago open democracy worked
with Senator Bradley on creating the
disclosure bill
it was actually about 10 years ago and
then after we passed a disclosure Bill
to get more groups to register and
report we noticed this loophole where
groups were instead of using those magic
words a vote for or vote against they're
using other words
to get around this loophole so basically
this is trying to plug the loophole by
saying if you clearly identify a
candidate within the time period and
it's not trying to get small groups it's
trying to get the big bigger groups that
are spending at least two thousand five
hundred dollars because you know
that a group that
spent time mailing this to a group of
Voters they've spent more than two
thousand five hundred dollars
um also just wanted to say
um
you might hear about some Court
decisions in other states and I want you
to know that political speech is
different and the first circuit has
looked at political speech and that we
can require disclosure if they are
making an act of spending money to
influence the election and voters
deserve that that
Integrity in the political process to be
able to look at the Secretary of State's
office and find out if the group
registered or reported I can tell you
most voters don't go to the Secretary of
State's office and go to the campaign
Finance filings and see if a group
registered a report like only democracy
nerds like me and maybe representative
Barry look up when when he gets
political mail did this group register
or report
um
I do want to share a little bit of
History this committee has seen this
bill before this is not the first time
you have seen this bill before this bill
has passed the senate 24-nothing in 2019
passed this committee 20 nothing
um it did not make it over the Finish
Line because the governor did veto it
that year but I do hope that this
committee will look at this bill
favorably to just say groups should
register and report if they are making
political contributions
it's a simple transparency so please
vote ought to pass house bill
um
195. this is the 2022 campaign mail I
have a whole stack in my office of 2020
mail 2018 mail 2016 Mayo uh you can see
that this is happening uh throughout our
his throughout history and also you know
if anyone wants to save their 2024 mail
you know we'll take it and this is
voters Republican voters that received
things for Jeb Bradley and Democratic
voters and independent voters like this
is we try to collect mail from multiple
different sources to see who's
registering and Reporting
with that I'm happy to take any
questions
representative there's very few people
that keep the political mail so we have
that in common my wife's comments to
throw it out
um and I should have asked this to
representative lamb she was up here but
I I kind of just noticed it it says in
the language here
um and are publicly distributed
um within 60 days we don't Define
publicly distributed and I know like one
of the very most common campaign tactics
are um you know these campaign staffers
will generate letters to the editor and
they'll ship it off to somebody to
publish another publication like you
know the newspaper
um would that count under this
um because that's you've got a political
expansion happening right you're paying
a staffer to generate campaign materials
it's going in somebody else's name and
then it's being publicly distributed
um and this part to be fair this
question probably shouldn't have been
asked of you but like I said I missed my
opportunity the representative Lane
maybe she can tell me later but
um it's something like reading this I'm
thinking like we don't really Define
publicly distributed so
thank you for the question and I think
the attorney general has in other
campaign Finance letters made reference
to this so if this Sharon Carson letter
got sent to voters in Franklin it
wouldn't actually meet that definition
because Sharon Carson isn't my state
senator so what the attorney general has
when they've tried to do campaign
Finance violations has said was it
distributed to voters in that District
so if you mailed something
that was intended to Manchester voters
to a different town then it wouldn't be
considered actually publicly distributed
that's how the attorney general has
defined it in violations prior but I
would you know maybe ask that you ask
Ann Edwards or somebody from the
Attorney General on how they're defining
is this just mailers or I don't know
bumper stickers uh well it actually our
disclosure laws apply more broadly to
mailers radio ads
um
lawn signs actually require disclosure
anything you're spending more than
twenty two thousand five hundred dollars
on aggregately
um you need to register
most people who are running for office
register and file their campaign Finance
reports
the majority of people do there are just
certain groups that are not registering
and Reporting and and this bill is just
trying to plug that loophole but it does
the definition in 664 does Define
commune all Community the communications
um and so Facebook ads do count I I
believe but somebody can correct me if
I'm wrong on on that
so if somebody sends out 2 500 bucks
worth of bumper stickers that say
Representative Steven Smith murders
third if if they put those all over cars
right now it wouldn't qualify if those
bumper stickers still are on cars close
to the election then it would qualify
that the person who spent the money
needed to register
um as a political group and
and disclose their spending
thank you and I would never hurt a
kitten
further questions
representative Brian thank you
of those letters that you have there how
many of them
you uh you have no idea where they came
from you can't determine what
organization organization or person sent
them
there's one in this pile that's that has
no disclosure disclosure whatsoever I'm
trying to find it
um they didn't say paid for by anything
and I wish I had like put them in a
put sticky notes on them because now
they're all out of order but there is
one that has no no disclosure no return
address no website
no indication of of anyone who they
spent money for
um there are others I will say that
some of them say paid for by and list a
Treasurer which is what you're supposed
to do you're supposed to list a
Treasurer and an address
um some of them don't all do that
so they're all over the place as far as
how our just how our law is supposed to
look and then what actually happens is
and anyone willing wanting to look
through them happy to make this pile
available
questions
representative
so if uh you see some of those and you
can't uh and they don't disclose who
they are and how can you make them
accountable will it uh be an
investigation by the Secretary of State
and so forth can you Enlighten us on
that I'm sure and I uh urge you to ask
the Attorney General's office but the
way it works currently is is and I know
that there has been campaign Finance
violations filed regular citizens can
send a letter saying I received this
mail and I don't know who it's from and
the Attorney General will investigate
who who mailed them sometimes they can
find out from the bulk permit number
because there's a bulk permit number on
it and they'll find out who who mailed
that in there are other ways that the
Attorney General can investigate who
sent these letters but I think by
passing this legislation we're just
saying anyone engaged in this activity
should register and Report that's all
not trying to stop anyone from doing any
of this political mail all this
political mail will still show up in
your inbox your mailbox we're just
saying that it should have who who paid
for it so voters can decide I think that
it's really important that voters become
informed consumers they are getting some
something telling them to vote for these
candidates and they can see that
Northwood Democratic committee Tom Chase
chair and Tom Ted Wilkinson treasurer
paid for it I think they're supposed to
thank you Mr chairman
now you said there was this is a
follow-up uh sort of for that last one
uh I received some mail like that myself
and I
pushed to get an investigation when you
received that mail that had no
information about who sent it did you
um I what I've I have been doing in
recent years open democracy has filed
complaints in years past but what I've
been doing is trying to train volunteers
who are collecting this mail for us so
that the voter who receives the mail
files the complaint because I do think
it's important that the voter who's
receiving the mail says this is
something that showed up in my mailbox
you know
it uh so that it's it's you know and and
also you know if there's multiple of
these that show up
um in multiple mailboxes
um and also things that have happened
like whether you see an ad in a
newspaper clipping Those ads in
newspapers that if they don't if they
haven't registered and Report reported
and spent money in in those
advertisements because I think it's
important for
our political discourse to know who's
representative quilly thank you Mr
chairman
how would this apply to an organization
or a person who was based outside of New
Hampshire and had no Presence at all in
New Hampshire in your opinion how would
that apply
well our our disclosure law says your
Treasurer must be from New Hampshire so
groups National groups that are spending
money outside do
ask for the treasurer to be from New
Hampshire so there's a lot of groups you
see
with a New Hampshire treasure there our
law I believe requires your Treasurer to
be from New Hampshire so we see a lot of
national groups that have Treasures in
New Hampshire for State male not for
federal mail this is for State male
um they do ask for the treasure to be in
from New Hampshire and we do see a lot
of groups that have New Hampshire
treasurers
some of them are the same person it's
really fun when you're like oh they've
just asked the same person to be the
for the questions
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee appreciate the opportunity to
speak here today my name is Greg Moore I
am the state director for Americans for
Prosperity and I'm here to testify in
opposition to house bill 195.
I will say this I've now been in this
role for 10 years and I have spent
countless countless hours spending time
with our in-house counsel outside
Council understanding compliance laws
and I think those are some things that
are really important to understand
there are basically five types of
communication political communication
that are sort of recognized from a legal
perspective the first is was called
voter and issue education
and that could be anything from
legislative scorecards to uh these uh
voter guides let's say citizens count uh
balladopedia other groups like that
this is just information not asking
anything of the voter making no ask of
the voter just pushing information now
that information May well come from the
perspective of that organization but
it's still it's still uh not asking
anyone to do anything the second second
group is called direct lobbying and
that's when someone with an orange badge
like this comes and talks comes talks
directly to you or sends you materials
or or whatnot uh the third group of
political communication is what's known
as Grassroots lobbying that's where an
organization would reach out to a
legislators constituents and ask them
encourage them to take a position on a
certain piece of legislation one of the
factors of that is it always includes
What's called the call to action at the
end meaning call call Representative so
and so and and at this number and tell
them to support X bill
uh then the last two groups or groups
that are basically decided by case law
the first one being is called Express
advocacy uh that was basically put in
play by Buckley vivallejo and that
Express advocacy is uh is basically what
was described as using the magic words
vote for elect send someone to send
someone a conquer don't send don't send
someone to Washington that's what's
called Express advocacy and then there's
What's called the functional equivalent
of Express advocacy that doesn't use any
of the magic words but speaks to uh a
candidate's a candidate's fitness or
temperament for office
ability to serve in office
representative Smith's that's the bumper
stickers you were talking about would be
the functional equivalence of Express
advocacy so those are the five buckets
that political communication resides in
and as far as regulation
uh this the courts have given have given
States broad ability to regulate
lobbyists like making me wear this
orange badge right now even though even
though technically this isn't lobbying
what I'm doing right now this isn't
lobbying that's those it's more for
those private conversations is what
lobbying is under RSA 15.
the express advocacy we regulate under
664 uh that's the majority when
someone's actually saying vote for vote
against that's covered under 664. the
original
of this uh Roman 11 Roman 12 we have
here
uh under defining political advocacy
organization is where in the past was
swept up the functional equivalent of
Express advocacy
that leaves the two other buckets one is
the Grassroots lobbying and the other is
voter and issue information
and the courts have a mixed a mixed view
on the ability to regulate Grassroots
lobbying as a prior prior uh person
mentioned prior speaker mentioned uh the
First District Court authorized
legislation symbol of this for the state
of Maine however more recently uh courts
in New Jersey and New York struck down
legislation similar to this so it's a
sort of a mixed mixed background and if
you're looking at the most recent cases
it's against the idea of trying to
regulate Grassroots lobbying and then
there's the final bucket which is voter
initial
voter and issue information and the
courts have been pretty clear that that
is fully protected by free speech and
that that can't well be regulated the
problem with the legislation you see at
hand is it sweeps all five of those
under one bucket for a discrete time
period but it sweeps it all up into one
bucket including everything from from uh
people going and I would imagine
citizens count for example would have to
register as a political advocacy
organization because I'm sure they spend
more than 2500 over the Arc of the year
and they do mentions candidates name
within the last 60 days
now who is doing
that type of voter and voter and issue
information in the last 60 days as well
as a lot of groups of League of Women
Voters again not telling you who to vote
for not calling anyone names not
encouraging you to vote for or against a
specific issue uh there are a lot of
groups out there most of those most of
those groups are are groups that are
pretty well open you know so
so you know I think you see a lot of
legislative scorecards come out close to
elections that's often a common thing as
well as as well as a lot of other
information talking about
um
information that might identify
candidate so saying something about
Governor sununu our governor sununa's
proposal would do this and that would be
vote information but that too would be
swept up and that is why that is why at
least in the New York and New Jersey
cases this legislation was viewed as
unconstitutionally overbroad
uh what is Grassroots lobbying within
the last 60 days well typically
typically as you know there's not a lot
of legislation that takes place in the
last 60 days before our primary general
election but some things do happen
within New Hampshire government we have
veto sessions we have uh nominations
before the executive Council we have
contracts that come before the executive
Council and if a group of people wanted
to opine on that particular issue I'll
give for example there was a I say the
most high profile one last year was the
issue of landfills there was a veto
override I know some people have looks
like they saw some scars from that one
but but that was that was an issue where
I think both sides spent over twenty
five hundred dollars they were weighing
in and they were encouraging people to
reach out to specific in that case
Senators to support the override of the
veto so this this bill would pull in
groups like that a lot of these groups
are fairly unsophisticated Community
groups
I think you're going to have a lot of
non-compliance If This Were to take
place you groups that just have no idea
that this would apply to them uh
particularly particularly folks who are
pushing out voter guides or things like
that they wouldn't appreciate that the
supplies to them and it would be it
would be pulling in a lot of those folks
uh in addition to that in addition to
that uh one of the things that's really
odd about this legislation is it strikes
the regulation of the functional
equivalence of Express advocacy but for
60 days before the primary in a general
so for example the bumper sticker that
rep that the chairman mentioned that
bumper sticker
they'd be required to uh under current
law when if they hit five thousand
dollars of spending they'd be they'd be
required to register as a political
advocacy organization at any point in a
cycle if they want to start calling
someone names or talk about their their
Fitness or uh quality of their candidacy
uh or Fitness to hold office but uh but
at this bill would stop regulating the
functional equivalence of Express
advocacy but for the last 60 days so if
someone were running a campaign for
governor and they wanted to just
basically make all sorts of wild
accusations if they're in a primary or
if they don't have a primary they just
want to start making all sorts of wild
accusations that could go completely
unregulated or another group that's
trying to support a candidate for
governor could make all sorts of wild
accusations that would have no no
responsibility to register with the
state whatsoever but for the last 60
days before primary in a general so I
think there are a lot of concerns that
we have with this legislation not the
least of which are some of the impacts
it would have on small groups that
really
are pretty unsophisticated uh could
potentially be set up for
for getting let's say let's say a group
that wants to weigh in on I know usually
it's late July early Late July that for
example Planned Parenthood
there the the Family Planning contracts
come up before the council that would
fall within the 60-day window so
suddenly they would have to register if
they wanted to say call Executive
counselor so and so and ask them to
support these contracts though that's
that's the type of stuff you'd be
pulling in if you were to pass this
legislation and I think that now a group
like Planned Parenthood would be fine
but maybe think of some of the smaller
health centers that maybe that maybe
don't have the type of operation behind
them they might miss out on something
like this and suddenly be breaking the
law so those are some of the concerns we
have but I at this point I'd be happy to
thank you
so in my County I'm not going to name
the town but there was a brutal gloves
off throw down over a warrant article to
build a new community center so if 25
people got together and each kicked in
100 bucks to send out a mailer
would this make them after register and
report I don't believe I believe this
applies to state only
um you'd have to I I'd encourage you to
reach out to the Department of Justice
and ask that question
I'm not I'm gonna I'm an engineer by
representative Barry
you're here representing Americans for
Prosperity
um would that how would this legislation
or would it impact your group at all
not per se I mean we
the only time we've weighed in on vetoes
uh has been in on budgets which tend not
to be near elections it's the the odd
number here
uh so it really doesn't have an impact
I'm not saying that that there might not
be a time where we might want to weigh
in on a veto one way or the other or
that uh I think the biggest impact it
would have directly for our organization
is uh depending on whether or not we
could just put it under our
see we have a political committee we
have to have a political committee and a
political advocacy organization then
that effect for us is it it might
accelerate how soon we get our our
legislative scorecard out
um so you know just so we don't have to
create another committee and go through
that compliance process and in two
different silos
uh I think probably taking my I'm here
today representing Americans for
Prosperity but I also happen to be the
state director for Americans for
Prosperity Foundation uh an AFP
Foundation was the organization that
brought litigation into New Jersey case
it overturned a similar law in Federal
District Court
um I I suspect uh AFP Foundation might
look closely at this legislation in
further questions
follow up I'm gonna ask you the same
similar question I asked um Miss sink
um publicly distributed
um with the supply to like when the
union leader endorses somebody for
governor would they then because that's
publicly distributed I'm assuming the
union leaders distribution costs more
than 2500 bucks
um it's an endorsement Express advocacy
for a candidate would that would they
didn't have to form a political obvious
organization in report
ah
you raise a great question because
you're bumping up against the
Constitutional uh provision
um that's the challenge because
technically this is so broad it could
bring in a newscast that mentions the
candidate's name because the news spends
more than twenty five hundred dollars a
year and as it turns out they tend to
mention candidates names within the last
60 days
um
and again that that's why I I'd
encourage I'd encourage the uh committee
to to reach out to the Department of
Justice to figure out if this law were
to pass how Department of Justice might
try to enforce it or if they would even
if they would enforce it because because
of some of the the challenges uh like
you just mentioned we've seen scenarios
like that
hello everyone again Aaron Hennessey I
am the deputy secretary of state and I
am here to just offer some information
on this bill
um just in general our office when when
the legislature
um makes changes to election laws we
like to see them clean things up and
just make them easier to read especially
for you folks I know we gave you a bunch
of information
um and the white and purple book is all
the election laws that we have in the
state and I hope you finish that I can
take questions on that right now too if
you'd like but um I just want to point
out that this bill in in my reading
causes a little bit more confusion than
it does clarification
for example the reference to on line
four to RSA 664 colon 2 comma
three refers back to a political
committee within the definition of a
political advocacy organization and when
you go when you go up and you read what
a political committee is and when you go
to the small D it also references a five
thousand dollar amount so if this were
to be passed as it is there would be a
reference where there's five thousand
dollars but there's also a 2500 and
which amount is it that you're supposed
to follow so just some confusion there
when reading what what's the intent
confusion between what the political
advocacy organization is definition wise
versus a political committee to
representative Barry's point the um in a
calendar year
um being in there but then down below on
line 11 60 days prior to a general
election
um I'm not from the Department of
Justice but I have worked with them a
bunch I do recommend reaching out to
them because the law the words online
10 and 11 publicly distributed
um does that mean that on 61 days before
the election if I drop off a bunch of
mailings at the post office that's when
it was publicly distributed but
57 days before the election when a voter
gets that mailing and they call US
Department of Justice because it doesn't
follow this law how are they going to
interpret that did it break the law did
it not break the law will it cause
unnecessary confusion for the people
getting the information for those trying
to send it out
and in the political committee section
it doesn't it has just a reference to a
full calendar year it doesn't make any
reference to the 60 days before so just
some inconsistencies that this creates
instead of clarifying up some
information
I think that's it
happy to take questions
thank you and I admire your optimism at
the mail we'll get there in four days
not in the North Country questions from
the committee
all right thank you thanks
foreign
sheet is four in favor one against uh
closest public hearing and house bill
195.
this guy never got here so but he's on
all right we will open the public
hearing on House Bill 196. welcome
representative Lane and I can't find
your card
okay so I'm representative Lane and I'm
from Ward 2 in Concord and thank you uh
for considering this bill
um again this is a campaign finance bill
that's basically trying to uh improve
our laws our existing laws which as we
just heard are a bit confusing and
um
and to look at what other states have
done in terms of transparency
the goal is to make everything as
transparent as possible and make it less
confusing
um so one of the ways of doing that is
to set up a committee or commission my
original bill that you all have set up a
commission I was told that it would be
more likely to pass if I changed it to
committee I don't really care whether
it's a commission or a committee so I
passed out to all of you when you came
back from lunch you should have this
unapproved amendment to 196. and my
thought was and basically what this bill
does is everywhere the word commission
pops up it substitutes committee so
that's the intent of the amendment
one of the recommendations of the
Secretary of State special committee on
voter confidence
is for the legislature to review the
body of election law
and this bill would do so related to
campaign Finance law it doesn't tackle
all the election laws just the campaign
Finance laws
now my hope is that the committee would
speak with campaign Finance reform
Advocates
review other states law talk with the
AG's office
and anyone they think we should talk to
there are some previous studies and
committees that have looked at this in
the past in New Hampshire and look at
that
um and then make recommendations so that
maybe we can draft some legislation and
consider it either next year or next
session
and that's it
okay
good afternoon
um my name is Olivia Zink and I live in
Franklin and I represent open democracy
action
we transparency is critical to our
democracy being open and accountable
having a study committee to study
campaign Finance is a good start in
improving our process
if this stays a commission or becomes a
committee I do hope that the legislature
will seek the views of the Secretary of
State and the Attorney General because
those were two appointed members and if
it's just a committee it's only
legislators but I do hope you will give
the two agents or two you know the
Secretary of State's office in the
Department of Justice a chance to have a
voice when this committee had their
organization day the Attorney General
Ann Edwards said to you that there are
1600 violations in 2020. I do think that
it's a good idea for us to look at those
violations figure out what's happening
maybe this this committee would make a
recommendation that the Secretary of
State's office and the Attorney General
hold a training so campaigns know how to
file their campaign Finance
makes sense to me
um
the there has been a bill that had has
failed but uh wanted to make sure that
the campaign Finance reports are legible
I have seen that the many reports are
not legible the Secretary of State's
office
um once uh Karen Ladd once told me that
her favorite way to get campaign Finance
reports are when a candidate fills them
out in pencil and faxes them so she
can't read them and I said why can't you
send them back and ask them to resubmit
them so you can read them and she's like
if that's not our job that's the
Attorney General's job to enforce the
law
I do think that there might be a way to
streamline that process so if somebody
fills out a report that's incomplete
doesn't have a signature missing
information
that there's a way for the Secretary of
State's office to just say can you
finish this information
followthemoney.org uh gives New
Hampshire an F on our campaign
disclosure we rank 48 out of 50 states
so I do think that this uh there is lots
of room to improve New Hampshire's
disclosure and and campaign Finance
um I think there will be some really
amazing ideas that come from a
bipartisan group of legislators look
reviewing campaign Finance reports
seeing if there's more efficiencies and
effective ways to keep this going
one idea might be
people fill out using the online
campaign Finance system so that it's
legible
um this this bill hopefully will
allow you to study the committee to
to look at maybe examining the cost of
campaigns the effectiveness of of New
Hampshire's disclosure law and our
enforcement constitutional options to
regulate campaign Finance
and specific revisions that might be
aimed at improving the integrity and
increasing public confidence in our
campaign Finance so please support House
Bill
196 or as amended
happy to take any questions
so this is just your Tuesday now that's
that's what's happening
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee Aaron Hennessey deputy
secretary of state just want to go on
record that we support this legislation
whether it's a commission or a committee
and would be happy to participate with
either the committee or as a member of
the commission
and as a former this is an aside as a
former eight-year user of these laws
um I I did find them confusing
unnecessarily
I think you just beat your last record
on brevity
we got thank you for taking my question
uh regarding
um establishing this commission or
committee does it have to be done by I'm
new to the board does it have to be done
by the election law uh committee or can
the can your office initiate this
foreign
thank you
that is a great question I imagine that
we could initiate something but we would
then have to come to you to say hey
would you listen to what we have to say
so I think it would be more effective
and efficient if you did it your within
okay follow up yeah
um on the the uh
the latest report that was done on voter
integrity was that brought up from this
and I wasn't here so I apologize was
that brought up through
um the lecture law committee or was it
brought up through the uh that was a
secretary of state's decision to form
that commission Okay so
How would
oh well
okay while she's here
uh how would that be different
how would that be different
just
so
um
the difference would be that that
commission identified some issues
um and if this commission to a were to
do the process itself usually a
commission or a committee will in their
recommendation and their final report
and this has just been my past
legislative experience have an actual
language of a bill that it's going to
thank you
yep so the idea is where's the reporting
so this will on November 1st
they must produce a report that goes to
the Speaker of the House the president
of the Senate the house clerk the Senate
clerk the governor and the State Library
so
that means both Senate President and the
speaker would get it it would come to
their attention and then there would be
recommendations from this committee
oh it says make recommendations when
when a state
legislature form committee makes
recommendations it's in the report but I
mean really what they're doing is filing
bills at that point
if the executive branch forms a
commission you get the report people may
read it or not but what it doesn't do is
oh
let's go on the blue sheet we have five
in favor none against that closes the
public hearing on House Bill 196. I
foreign
okay all right let's open the executive
I did the same thing this morning if you
did yeah oh okay
somebody said the word retain and so my
head switched modes
yeah so public hearing let's do that
welcome representative Hamer
thank you I'm Heidi Hamer from
Manchester and I'm introducing House
Bill 209 relative to The Forum required
to request an absentee ballot
this simple Bill simplifies the form
required to request an absentee ballot
this new form is trying to make it
easier for our challenged voters to vote
absentee ballot many absentee voters are
elderly or disabled
some absentee voters work long hours or
have long commutes and are unable to
make it to the polls on Election Day
during regular hours
some voters are combined confined to
jail for a misdemeanor or while waiting
trial they have a right to vote by
absentee ballot
there are voters who are caring for a
child or an adult they also
are unable to come to the polls and vote
in person
they also have the right to vote
absentee
well you could be on vacation lucky you
filling out this simplified form to
request an absentee ballot will help
those voters and make our city clerks
Town clerks jobs easier
my Manchester city clerk has done
countless in-home visits especially the
elderly voters because they do not
understand the current request forms so
this is my version of making everyone's
absentee ballot request easier
thank you
questions from the committee
okay what
representative Barry
um sorry I reviewed this when you sent
to me and I'm sorry I didn't get back to
you uh are you making any changes to the
requirements to request an absentee
ballot like you're not opening it up to
just anybody like all you're doing is
streamlining the actual page right yeah
okay
further questions
okay thanks thank you
John dodgy
okay
thank you Mr chairman Aaron Hennessey
deputy secretary of state
um I want to applaud the representative
for trying to simplify something
um for those of you who have not seen
a absentee ballot application this is
what one looks like right now and again
this is the legislature sets what goes
on here
um and there's a bunch of different
reasons there's reasons if it's there's
a snowstorm
um and then you have to flip it over
one thing I will point out
um to representative Barry's question
earlier I believe it does remove one
thing from the current
um
application in which it currently on the
application it says that if um your apps
and from
where you live or you're disabled and
not able to come in and register to vote
you can have an
um a registration sent to you with the
absentee ballot materials and I don't
see that on the on the new Option
um
and then also I just wanted to
make a suggestion that if you are going
to simplify
our constitution
uh in the part first article 11 gives
two options for absentee voters and that
is the disability or absence and it
would be much easier if you just had two
different check boxes and defined what
those things were so I can't
um be at the polls I need a absentee
ballot and it's a one of two reasons and
you make definitions for those two
reasons which
we have already defined in previously
I'm happy to take questions thank you
questions from the committee
representative Lane
thank you Mr chair thank you
Miss Tennessee
[Music]
um
I want to speak to your comment about
that because
part of the reason that we expanded out
this way is because people technically
they're not out of town
they're not away from their town if they
say are sitting in jail
so the idea so people wouldn't check
that or they they couldn't use that and
they didn't have a disability so we
heard testimony I think last year the
year before and tried to clarify that
that was part of the reason we wanted to
clarify it so people would understand
that it would qualify for that
thank you for the question and that can
still be included within the definition
in one of those two boxes it's just a
suggestion if you're trying to simplify
things
for the questions
representative Kelly
uh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Deputy uh
Tennessee
uh a note in in RSA 657-1
regarding excuses for absentee voting
it also includes
a National Weather Service winter storm
warning on the Monday before the
election
is I don't think that's in this
simplified version but wouldn't that
still need to be there
uh one it's uh
paragraph Roman numeral two or section
Roman numeral two
so I I don't have that in front of me
but I do have the our current
application and which does include that
and the two reasons for
um for the storm for you to get an
absentee ballot would be that you're
elderly informed or have a physical
disability and would otherwise vote in
person but have concerns for their
safety traveling in the storm they think
that would fit under the disability
um option for you to check
um also I anticipate that school child
care or adult care will be canceled and
would otherwise vote in person but will
need to care for children or affirmed
adults and that again is already an
absentee
excuse that you can have
so I think it's just duplicative of what
the
reasons we already have in law
and I'm sorry if I'm not being clear
enough so we already have a reason where
you if you're caring for a child or or
an adult you can get an absentee ballot
if you're unable to come to the polls
and we already have a reason if you have
a disability and if you for some reason
can't go outside when it's slippery or
you can't drive when it's snowing
I believe that would be covered under
follow up uh yes a follow-up uh I have
it in front of me I believe it's the
current version and
in the
the first excuse under the weather
service
storm warning
it doesn't make any reference in the RSA
itself to being disabled or infirm it
simply says if you're in fear
for your safety traveling in the
prospective storm that you can use that
as being absent
so I'm I'm just thinking and
that the application would need to have
that corrected if we left it in so I
don't think it's covered elsewhere but
you'll check me on this I'm sure when
you have a chance
thank you thank you I
I can get a legal opinion as to whether
that would be a
fall under disability or not but
again if you want to leave all of that
in there then then this is what your
[Music]
um back to the disability
um and I just heard that you were going
to check on that but a few years ago we
were told that disability when we were
working on the National Weather Service
built that it would not cover the things
that are set out in that bill okay so I
just wanted
that was part of the reason it went into
the bill so ask again if you would
please if they think that if that's the
thank you I will follow up on that
definition and I apologize I was I was
never on Election law and so I was not
okay
foreign
and the blue sheet please representative
wood
and on on the blue sheet we have one in
favor chew against and that closes the
public hearing on House Bill 209
uh the Republicans members will caucus
in the uh the staff room uh is there
going to be a Democrat Caucus
okay and make sure all your microphones
are turned off when you do caucus
representative
okay it's three o'clock
we'll open the executive session on
House Bill 115. representative Berry is
recognized for a motion uh yes I'd like
to uh retain House Bill one more time
115 I think I don't have my notes in
um per the request of the sponsor uh we
want to hold on to this there's a
similar legislation in the Senate so we
want to kind of sit back and see what's
going to go on over there and then we
will make our move forward at that point
after working on the bill and talking
with ourselves
foreign
okay the motion is we oh the motion is
retained from the clerk will call the
roll
I'm a little nervous now that um the
boss is in the room I'm better make this
quick before I get fired no I'm kidding
kidding everyone
um so the motion is to retain hb115
and um starting with representative
Barry yes
representative Barry votes yes um
representative prudhoma yes
representative Bohm yeah
representative yes uh representative
quaily yes
representative qualey votes yes
representative Sweeney
yes representative Sweeney votes yes
representative Burnham
yes representative Vernon votes yes
representative Kennedy
representative Kennedy votes yes
representative weary
representative weary votes yes
representative wood
yes representative wood votes yes uh
representative Lane
yes
representative Lane votes yes uh
representative Ward
representative Ward votes yes
representative Hamer yes representative
Hammer votes yes representative Hamlet
yes Senator pamphlet votes yes
representative page
representative page votes yes
representative Bay
yes representative Bay votes yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Brennan votes yes
representative Grill I vote Yes
uh representative Howard
yes representative Howard votes yes
representative Palmer yes representative
Palmer votes yes and uh representative
Smith yes representative Smith votes yes
that makes for
um 20 years and no Nays so that is
unanimous
and
um
that closes the executive session in
open the executive session on House Bill
333 representative Berry is recognized
for a motion uh yes I'm about to retain
would you like to speak to your motion
yes uh after attending the chairs of
Vice chairs meeting this morning the
clerk of the house said that we should
retain all the bills I'm just kidding
yeah
um
[Music]
no it's the same reason as the bill
before uh the sponsor wants to sit back
and work on it and see what other
pending legislations coming forward and
moving through the bodies but I thought
I could that little dig in there
pretty sure he would have said the
opposite
is there a further discussion on the
bill
okay
clerk will call the roll
all right twice in a row
um representative Barry yes
representative Barry votes yes
representative prudhome O'Brien yes
Senator O'Brien votes yes
representative boam yes representative
boom votes yes representative qualey yes
representative quaylee votes yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Sweeney votes yes
representative Burnham
yes representative Brandon votes yes
representative Kennedy representative
Kennedy votes yes representative weary
yes representative weary votes yes
representative wood
yes representative wood votes yes
representative Lane
yes representative Lane votes yes
representative Ward yes representative
Ward votes yes representative Hamer yes
representative Hammer votes
representative Hamlet yes representative
Hamlet votes yes representative page
representative page votes yes
representative Bay
yes Senate Bay votes yes representative
Brennan yes representative Brennan votes
yes
representative girl I vote Yes
representative Howard
yes representative Howard votes yes
representative Palmer yes Senator Palmer
votes yes and uh representative Smith
yes
representative Smith votes yes that is
another 20 2-0
let's keep it going just trying to hook
people up and that closes the executive
session on House Bill 333 345 will be
next
we'll open the executive session on
House Bill 345 representative Hamlet is
recognized for a motion
thank you Mr chairman I move to retain
House Bill 345 FN
would you like to speak to your motion
yes I would
so the sponsors are confident that
ranked Choice voting is fully is easy to
use Easy to implement and is fully
constitutional
uh when voters have the opportunity to
use it they like it and it gives a more
accurate measure of the will of the
people
than our current voting system
although the bill already has bipartisan
support
we would like to broaden the base of
support in order to gain strong support
across our communities so please vote to
retain the house bill 345.
clerk will call the roll please
all right
um representative Barry yes
representative Trudeau O'Brien yes
representative Bohm yeah
representative qualey yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Burnham
oh yes
representative Kennedy
representative weary
representative wood
yes
representative Lane yes
representative Ward
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative page
representative Bay
yes
representative Brennan yes
um representative Grill I vote Yes
representative Howard
uh yes
and representative Palmer
and representative Smith yes
once again that is big surprise 20 yeses
zero no's and zero non-voting so that is
motion
emotions adopted and that closes the
we'll open the executive session on
House Bill 350 representative Hamlet is
recognized for a motion thank you Mr
chairman
um I moved to retain house bill 350.
second
would you like to speak to your motion
yes please so similar to House Bill 345
um we are confident that ranked Choice
voting is easy to use Easy to implement
and is fully constitutional we would
like more time to educate the public and
broaden our bipartisan support so please
uh support the motion to retain by
all right the clerk will call the roll
all right one last time for the day
representative Barry yes
representative purdom O'Brien yes
representative Bohm yes
representative qualey yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Burnham yes
representative Kennedy
representative weary
representative wood yes representative
Lane yes representative Ward yes
representative Hamer yes
representative Hamlet yes
representative page yes
representative Bay
yes representative Brennan yes
representative Krill I vote Yes
representative Howard
no
okay
representative Palmer yes
all right that is 19 years and one nay
Thomas I didn't forget you
we'll just blame representative Howard
threw me for a loop I'm kidding
um that is uh 19 years and one nay and
zero non-voting and the motion is still
adopted
and that closes the executive session on
House Bill 350.
so uh planning for the future
I serve on another committee and they
meet on the same day because you know
planning and uh so I have to go there in
the afternoon so what I plan to do here
is from now on when we exact bills we'll
do them earlier in the day so I don't
want to change the political makeup of
the committee because you had traffic or
there was a
moose in the roads so we'll probably do
one public hearing it gives people an
opportunity to come in late and then
we'll exec bills before lunch and do the
remainder of the public hearings in the
afternoon I gotta look at the schedule
but it should work out that way so
that's the plan